wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some amazing
motivation from the one and only bob
proctor
the one thing you need if you want to
move higher
is a greater awareness
[Music]
people are not earning a hundred
thousand a year because they want to
earn a hundred thousand a year they're
earning a hundred thousand a year
because they're not aware of how to earn
a hundred thousand a month
people aren't alone and lonely because
they enjoy being alone and lonely
they're alone and lonely because they're
not aware of how to build meaningful
relationships
people don't struggle all of their
commercial career
because they enjoy struggling they're
struggling because they're not aware
of how to knock those blocks down that
are all inside it's never outside it's
never another person it's never a
condition or a circumstance
it's always lack of awareness
this is such beautiful information
been living with it for a long time
i don't even know how you'd live without
it
in fact i don't think you can you merely
exist and unfortunately that's the way
most people go through life
you see our educational institutions is
not giving us the same kind of
information they really don't they
really believe the secret is read the
book
remember what's in the book and be able
to repeat it answer the questions
more right than wrong you'll pass you
get the degree well we've got people
graduating from some of the most
prestigious universities in the world
every year
[Music]
with multiple degrees
they're having difficulty finding work
that are broke how does that happen
and yet you'll find other people who are
functionally illiterate they can either
read or write they're earning millions
how do we account for this
you're going to find that out
as you study this
it's got nothing to do with anything
outside of ourselves
education isn't answering what's in the
book
education comes from the latino juco
meaning to reduce to or to draw from
within remember i said everything's
already here omnipresent that's within
us
men in montessori was right
napoleon hill was right
carnegie knew the right question
hill knew how to answer it
what are you going to do with the rest
of your life
[Music]
that's your question
you got to make a decision we have here
in the subconscious the paradigm and
part of the paradigm
with respect
to money
is
it's a poverty thing
now this paradigm
impacts our thinking there's a power
flowing into our consciousness
and the thoughts we think
are generally
motivated by the subconscious mind
now something that i've been
pointing out here recently
on look at this
the subconscious mind is universal
intelligence
so when you have that paradigm in the
subconscious mind
that controls the vibration that we're
in
and the vibration we're in is going to
dictate what we attract because we're in
that vibration here on a conscious level
on a subconscious level and on a
physical so you're going to attract from
anywhere you go in the universe the same
type of thing that's that's what we're
attracting
so we're attracting people that are in
harmony with this and this paradigm
causes our thinking to be along the same
level
now
we've got to realize even in our
ignorance when we don't know and we
haven't got anything
our thinking is hooked into universal
intelligence
and you will attract from wherever it is
in the universe whatever is required
to cause the problem when you hear
people say you know i just get one
filled bill paid and another one pops up
bang they're going to attract it
and sure as it gets dark they get it
now that's ingrained in our mind from
the time we're children
in fact
from the moment of conception in most of
us
and then we grow into it and that's what
we hear as we're growing up money
doesn't grow on trees and and over and
over you can't have everything you want
you know
and
that is
that's got to be eliminated
and we've got to realize that is not
fact
that you do not have to work harder
that you do less
and you earn more
and you've got to get the idea that you
can have money coming in from many
different places in the world dragging
it right into you
you attract it
and you can magnetize yourself
to money
in all different quantities although you
cannot change conditions or circumstance
you don't have to let them control you
we can't control what's going on outside
but we can control what's going on
inside
you know
and
unfortunately i don't think many of us
have been raised to really understand
that yeah
and it's a lack of understanding that's
causing all our problems we are the only
creature on the planet
that's totally disoriented in our
environment
all the little squirrels the birds the
every all the animals
are completely at home in their
environment they blend in
you and i are totally disoriented in our
environment we've been given the mental
faculties to create our own environment
however we go right through school we've
never learned that
we have higher faculties
and the average person has no knowledge
of how to operate with them how to
develop them we have perception the will
reason imagination memory and intuition
now those mental faculties they're not
just words
they're actually mental faculties that
we can use
to take control over our world and to
create the environment that we want
but unfortunately we grow up we don't
know that we've been raised to live
through by what we see hear smell taste
and touch
our physical senses and we're we've been
raised to be controlled by what's going
on outside
as little kids will you listen to what
i'm telling you will you look at this
you know and so it's all outside
um we get our report card and that tells
us what kind of student we are
but it really tells us where our mind
was at for a few minutes three weeks ago
got nothing to do with who we are
so i think we're
we're raised in ignorance actually
there's a very small percentage of the
population that
have a reasonably
clear understanding of who they are and
what they're capable of doing but
the ones that do are in the minority the
future must become the present in the
imagination
of the one who would wisely and
consciously create circumstances
i think right now everybody wants to
create circumstances because they don't
like the ones they find themselves in
but you see you cannot change the
circumstance you find yourself in
you can only change your perception of
them and when you do that you change the
circumstance so we say here the future
must become the present in the
imagination of the one who would wisely
and consciously create circumstance we
must translate vision into being
[Music]
thinking of into thinking from
imagination must center itself in some
state and then view the world from that
state
see yourself where we want to be and
then be there
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world of fulfilled
desire
that is so cool
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world of fulfilled
desire so what are we doing we're
building a goal and then we see ourself
already haven't accomplished a goal
thinking from the end is an intense
perception of the world of fulfilled
desire already got it i don't have to
get it i've already got it
that's an intense perception
of the world of fulfilled desire in
other words you got it it's here
now think are you thinking from the end
are you thinking of the end if you're
thinking of the end your thing is way
out there if you're thinking from the
end you're part of it
see
the end result has already happened in
our mind we're creative beings we're
god's highest form of creation
we can create in our consciousness the
kind of person we want to be and then be
that person and that's what he said here
we must
translate vision into being
so we don't just visualize it we be it i
set a goal in 1973
i set a goal that i was going to build a
company and upgrade all over the world
i had
left the nightingale cornet corporation
and decided that i was going to do this
because i didn't agree with the way they
were doing it
people weren't really learning it fast
enough
and they wouldn't get involved in the
repetition we were selling recordings
but the recordings weren't working
because the people didn't understand how
to use them
so i decided i would leave and start my
own company
and i wrote down i'd build a company and
operate all over the world i got a call
last night from mikey about nine o'clock
something like that
and then she told me
that we were now
in every country in the world
now think of that
we had a broadcast going on here at 10
o'clock this morning
some of you'd be familiar with it some
of you may have been on it
and
that broadcast had attracted thousands
literally thousands of people
from every country in the world
the goal was reached
that move
meant this is really accurate today
we're only limited by weakness of
attention and poverty of imagination
well my imagination was pretty well
exercised i don't have any difficulty
building huge ideas in my mind and just
figuring out how to do it
now stay with me here
the thing that's stopping you
from taking the risk that you want to
take
is called a terror barrier
the way i'm going to explain this to you
i come up with sitting in a restaurant i
remember it was at a holiday inn
restaurant
it was at dixie and
just south of the 401 highway
in toronto
a man asked me if i would meet with him
he had a problem
and i was going to show him how he could
solve the problem
and he explained it so i took a pen and
some paper and what i'm going to show
you here is essentially what i showed
him
now look at this for a moment
there is the process you go through
when you're in a risk-taking vibration
you go from bondage
to reason
to the terror barrier and then to
freedom
you go from
bondage to reason
to the terror barrier
and then to freedom but we have to go
way back to 1908. things were pretty
primitive then relative to today we
weren't moving at the speed we're moving
at now
napoleon hill was a young reporter for a
little magazine
and someone probably the editor decided
they would run a series of articles of
interviewing wealthy people
hill was fortunate enough to get an
interview a three-hour interview
with the wealthiest man in the world
andrew carnegie
and he went and he sat and he
interviewed him now unbeknownst to
napoleon hill
andrew carnegie was looking for someone
that he could give a big project to
and he hadn't yet found anyone
at the end of the three-hour interview
andrew carnegie said to napoleon yell
napoleon
this interview isn't ending it's just
beginning
i want you to come home with me
hill said he was glad he took him home
because he didn't have enough money to
rent a hotel room
he spent three days with andrew carnegie
the wealthiest man in the world now
think of this
[Music]
over those three days
andrew carnegie shared his philosophy
she started out as a poor boy
immigrated from scotland
with his parents just as a boy they
didn't have anything
so he went from nothing to be the
wealthiest man in the world and he
shared with napoleon hill his whole
philosophy
at the end of the three days
carnegie decided that
i think this is the man i'm looking for
i guess you could tell by his level of
interest in the story
the philosophy of what got him to where
he was
there was probably a number of factors
came into play
but carnegie think i think he's the guy
and so he asked him a question
unbeknownst to napoleon hill he only
gave him 60 seconds to answer the
question
and at the end of the 60 seconds he
would have to make a decision a
monumentous decision
if you think about it
he looked at him
he had a stopwatch in his hand under his
desk
and he says napoleon you've spent three
days with me you know now
how i've accomplished what i've
accomplished
is i'm going to ask you a question and i
just want a yes or no answer
just a yes or no answer nipple
he said would you spend or invest the
rest of your life
in an idea for which you would probably
receive no material compensation
for at least 20 years
[Music]
how would you answer that question i've
asked myself on many occasions how i
would answer it
in 25 seconds napoleon hill said yes he
would
he qualified
he passed the acid test
and he had to make a decision
that was a big decision
you're going to run up against decisions
this is one of the 13 principles
napoleon hill wrote a whole chapter on
decision
in his book think and grow rich
and right on the very first page he
points out that all successful people
make decisions very fast they change
them very slow if and when they change
them at all
and he pointed out that people that are
not successful make decisions very slow
and change them fast and often
i guess that's why andrew carnegie gave
him 60 seconds
if he took longer
he would be disqualified what's the
thing that you don't want to learn and
understand that you feel like you know
what i haven't fully grasped this
concept or idea and i really want to get
to another level
well i'm always wanting to get to
another level hopefully i'm at a higher
level today than i was yesterday i i'm
in here
around 5 30 every morning studying wow
that's how i start my day here well
you see
there is no end to the growth
you you always want to grow
so
you're created in god's image
now there's a problem with this
because we're raised on our physical
senses
we grow up
and what we've done is had god created
in our image in our mind
not that we're creating god's image
we're taught that we created god
in our image
so now we're trying to figure out how
can the man be omnipresent
how can that person be everywhere and
because we're locked in on a physical
level we get lost
when we understand
that you have infinite potential there
is no top
there's no beginning no end
see when it comes to school of greatness
there is no finish line
when it comes to personal development
there is no finish line
so how can you tell how well you're
doing by the results you're getting
by their fruit by their food you'll know
them by the results they're getting
if they're not getting the results they
don't know
so if you're going to get a mentor get
somebody that's getting the results yeah
or you don't want them now you see here
on page six it says money is a servant
it's a servant
now there's a myth about money says
another myth about money like you accept
money is that it only comes as a result
of luck or good fortune
well of course that is really silly
that's not true at all but that's the
concept that a lot of people operate
with okay
now if you move over onto page seven
we're talking about money's got to
circulate it's not only a server you got
to keep it moving
i have some money here in my pocket
i keep it a little envelope
and
this stuff here
is money
the truth is this represents money
now this used to be paper now i think
it's plastic you know use it as a fan
but this is
it's a servant and you can put this to
work
you got to keep it circulating
now we tell a story in here
about um
mr chapman now mr chapman was an
interesting guy
he lived on the street that i lived on
as a little boy
and my brother and i had a paper route
and we sold
papers to the people on that street we
had 300 customers went right from
kingston road to the lake ontario
and almost every house we had as a
customer
mr chapman had a big house not too far
from our house up on a hill it was an
old house
and one day mr chapman we used to feel
sorry for him he was he was hunched back
he was a little man he used to push a
little cart around and he collected junk
his wife was a a tall thin lady
and
she always wore
just
skimpy clothes like
a cotton dress with a maybe a little
coat running shoes
and she would be off up the street she
wanted to clean houses or clean offices
we thought they were really poor well
one day we opened the paper we went up
the corner to get the papers and when we
got the delivery of the papers it was
headlines that mr chapman had died
it was a headline in the toronto star
they found a hundred thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars in a jar in the
house here he is collecting junk and he
had a hundred thousand dollars in a jar
in the house
now i just looked up that that up this
morning that's equal to one million
eighty seven thousand seven hundred and
ninety eight dollars in today's dollars
that's what a hundred thousand in 1947
would have been uh in today's dollars
it'd be over a million a million 87
88 000.
he had all this money and he had it in a
jar
it was serving no one it wasn't
circulating
and we were shocked that he even had it
so
what we've got to understand
is that saving it like that is silly
like here the money that's in this
envelope in my pocket it's useless as
long as it's in an envelope in my pocket
it does no one any good
you may be saying while you're keeping
it there it won't stay
it won't stay there very long i'll have
it circulating in a very short period of
time now if you come down to the bottom
of page nine these are just basics we're
talking about here about a prosperity
consciousness exercise
now that we have touched upon some of
the characteristics of money let us turn
briefly to a simple technique
which you can begin using immediately
to start attracting the amount of money
that you desire now think of that
you can literally attract to you
the amount of money you desire you've
got to ask yourself
where do i stand with money you're
building an idea
and you're planting it in universal
intelligence
now when you do that
when you do that what you want to
understand
is that
you've planted that idea
here
that idea then
is planted in universal intelligence so
it's drawing from anywhere
anything that's in harmony with it
you see this
is a vibration it's a frequency
and we have put ourselves on a specific
frequency when you hold that idea when
you're emotionally involved that must be
expressed with and through you whatever
you need is in the universe and this
idea is going to attract it to you
because the idea controls the vibration
that you're in the vibration you're in
controls what you how you act but it
also controls what you attract
this is very important you get this your
subconscious mind is um
it's like universal intelligence
and
that idea then
is on a specific frequency
hold on
we're spiritual beings
this is the spiritual side of you now
everything spirit
the intellect and the physical
but when you plant the idea here
it's planted on a specific frequency
it's almost like
when i phone somebody
what i'm doing is i'm tuning in on a
particular frequency and they're on that
frequency
and when i press a number their phone
rings doesn't matter where they are
they could be anywhere in the world you
see when it comes to universal
intelligence you eliminate all time and
space there's no such thing as time and
space everything's in the now everything
is in the now
and it's important that we understand
that
and when we understand it good things
start to happen to us
okay
now that idea
or will attract to it
anything that's in harmony with it
so whatever you need will come to you
but it won't come to you before you need
it
and we're very impatient and we want to
do
this part before we get this part done
you're going to do things in the order
you see this part is operating by law
it's operating by law
because it's universal intelligence and
the law is perpetual transportation of
energy that idea instantly begins to
move into form
and it attracts whatever is required but
it also causes you to act the way you
have to act so it's the action and
attraction that ultimately produces the
result
how long does it take for that to
manifest we don't know
that's governed by a law called law of
gender that law decrees that all things
have a gestation or an incubation period
see the only criteria you have to have
when you set a goal is do you want it
do you want it doesn't matter how you're
going to do it it doesn't matter where
their money's coming from
i once heard a creep story where the
maharashi when he was taking
transcendental meditation or decided he
was going to take it to the world one of
his close associates said
where's the money going to come from
he said wherever it is right now
i always thought it was such a beautiful
answer because the truth
everything you need everything you want
is already here
nothing is created or destroyed i didn't
bring this up it's the way it is all
science all theology tell us that the
way to get the moon was already here
always here
when president john kennedy asked dr
warner von braun who's considered the
father of the space travel what it would
take to build a rocket that would carry
a man to the moon and bring him back
safely to earth
von braun answered him in five words the
will to do it
the will to do it will is a mental
faculty that gives us the ability to
concentrate you got to concentrate on
what you want that's all you can
concentrate on
and that will keep you on the frequency
that you have to be on to attract
everything that you need to get there
this is so important
to see i believe decision where it all
starts
it's where it all started for napoleon
hill
it all started when carnegie asked him
are you prepared
to dedicate the rest of your life to an
idea
for which you'll probably receive no
material compensation
for at least 20 years how would you
answer that
you see he didn't know how to do that
he didn't even believe he could
do you know what i found when you set a
goal you don't have to believe it
if you keep repeating it you'll come to
believe it
if you tell yourself a lie often enough
you'll believe it
way back in 1900 william james from
harvard he said believe that your belief
will create the fact
so true
so true and so misunderstood
so what do you want
compare your dream
to napoleon hill's idea
just compare it for a moment
your idea is probably small by
comparison
but if you don't know how to do it if
you don't know where the money's coming
from if you don't know where the help's
going to come from
you'll probably seem large
when i took my pen
and i sat down and i wrote i would build
a company that operated all over the
world
i had no idea how i was going to do it i
certainly didn't have the finances to it
i didn't have the help i didn't even
have an assistant
i was just me
in my den
writing on a pad
do you know something
today
i own a company
along with sandy gallagher who is my
business partner and we operate all over
the world
these aren't accidents
i'm just an ordinary guy
that's doing what the public would
consider something extraordinary but
it's not extraordinary to me and it's
not going to be to you when you start to
understand these principles and
incorporate them into your life i
mentioned we want to build schools in
africa
for kids that have never seen a school
and so we're building them
there's many things we want to do we do
them all i never wonder if i can do
something
i just ask myself do i want to
that's why i think god meant us to live
i believe we're doing god's work
somebody said what's god's word god well
if god's the creator then god's work
would be creation we've been given the
mental faculties to create
we've been created in god's image
somewhere along the line way back when
somebody got that mixed up
they thought when they said you're
creating god's image that god was
created in their image so they're
looking for a man on a cloud there is no
man on a cloud
but i'm going to tell you something
you got some phenomenal stuff locked up
inside of you
you bring it to the surface
you can have anything you want
it's a great way to live it's pretty
well known today there's a lot of fear
in the world
people are wondering what's going to
happen we've gone through many tough
times if you study history
i was born during the great depression
so i was of an age then i remember some
of the things as a little kid
then we went into a world war
and when the depression ended
it was sort of like a theater where the
lights were out it was empty but the
lights started to come up
and things started to get brighter
and of course they became very bright
so
the fear
don't let fear control you fear is a
negative emotion
by following these principles you're
going to be on the other side of fear
where there's faith
there's a law of the universe called
polarity
that law decrees everything has an
opposite
every negative has a positive
the truth is it's neither positive or
negative
it's our thinking that makes it so
everything just is we can make it what
we want
make up your mind now
you're going to go in the positive
polarity you're going to stay with me
because that's where i'm going
and there'll be a very bright future
let the fear go
it isn't necessary
the cause of it is ignorance the cause
of all fear is ignorance if you want
something you haven't got you got to
create a space for it if it's in your
own mind you've got to let go of
something
so what do we want to do to let go if we
want to let go of the image we've got
for the one we're going to build
now i'm going to be honest with you when
i started to do this
[Music]
um i tested it just
i thought i wonder if this really work
and i found that it really worked
so i went all out
and
you start out by writing
the image that you want to hold
i'll tell you how i did it
i um
i took various people that i really
admired
and i took some of the qualities that i
really admired in them and i'd write
them down
i wasn't going to be like them but i was
going to develop a couple of these
qualities or habits when i was growing
up as a young guy it was during the
second world war
there was no men around no fathers
but one guy did have a father donny
miller's father had was not well so he
couldn't go to the war
and um
donny's dad had a heart attack or
something it was i think it was a heart
attack
and so we never went around his place
because his dad wanted things quiet
they'd come around our place but not
donny's place i would watch
donny's dad walk up and down the street
you see him go way up the street later
on you'd see him come back
he was always well dressed and he had
the calmest walk
there was no rush just a very calm walk
i visualize myself walking like him
you'll very rarely ever see me rushing
anywhere there's no need of it
you can be calm
when i built my self-image
i built it around certain things ray
stanford
always had money
i told you earlier i don't know how to
get into this thing now
always have some money
always
now
i hardly ever use it
because i really don't pay for very much
i get somebody in the company to order
whatever i want
but you see i never had any money ray
always had a roll on him
he would have a roll like that in his
pocket all the time now there's about
three thousand dollars here this is not
about there is three thousand dollars
here
you see
well
i only earned four thousand dollars a
year at that time three thousand dollars
would have been a ton of
money
but
everybody has different little quirks
i like to carry money
i and it's probably because i never had
any
and now
i have some money i want to carry it but
you see i started to do that before i
had any money
and i would take
and i would put
phony money in a roll but i would have
the right thing on the outside it was
the thickness of it
my mind didn't know the difference i
knew intellectually the difference and
then shortly i didn't even pay any
difference to that it was the feel of it
i did different things i watched
different people i saw how this person
did this and somebody else did that
i am
i read a lot so i read a lot of great
self-help books
and
i literally did what some of these books
suggested
it wasn't just sometimes i did it
i would follow it right to a t
you'll very rarely see me without a suit
on
that's part of the paradigm
that's part of the paradigm
i don't care what anybody else does how
they dress
i'm always going to be dressed
i
mentally made up my mind one time i'd be
at least
if i wasn't the best dress one of the
best race people in the room
why did i do that
i did that because i was changing how i
saw me
how i saw me i had never gone to school
i had no money i had
dumb jobs
and today
along with sandy gallagher i have a
company operates all over the world
right here on my desk i have sitting
this little
hourglass
well you know i can't put anything where
that hourglass is until i get rid of it
and we find that we want things to come
into our life but we don't create room
for them
nature
abhors a vacuum i remember
we were
sitting in the living room having a cup
of coffee
and just visiting and she said do you
mind if we go and sit in the kitchen
there's none at all
so
so i asked her i said
why do you want to sit in the kitchen
rather than she says i can't stand that
room i just hate living in that sitting
in that room she's i hate those curtains
that are on the window in the dining
room and the drapes on the front window
and i said no you don't hate those mark
i said you only have attract things to
you that you love that you're in harmony
with
i said if you really didn't love them
you get rid of them
but you see i'm going to put that
i'm going to put them there if i get rid
of them i said mark
if you had something to put there you
couldn't put it there because you've
already got something there
and i said that's when i started
teaching the law
of vacuum law prosperity
certainly she went and got a chair and
got up and stood on she started to take
all these curtains down well done he was
wearing like a
stuffed peg he said what are you doing
and she says i'm getting rid of these
and she did
wasn't too long after i dropped in all
the furniture in the living room was
gone
it was like they were just moving into
the place
but then they got new curtains and then
they got new furniture and you know
everything in that business in that
house changed it wasn't too long they're
only in business for themselves they're
both gone now but when they left they
were very well off they had a beautiful
place in florida they'd go to the winter
the family still runs their own business
i mean it was it was such a beautiful
thing to see and it was all and i tell
the story in here because it was all
about the vacuum law of prosperity
well what have you got in your life that
you don't want
or that you don't like
or what is it that you've got that you
really want to get rid of
you've got to get rid of this stuff get
rid of it give it away
see nature truly does abhor a vacuum
when you make space for the good that
you desire that's when the goods going
to come most people don't make the space
for the good that they desire now the
law of polarity decrees everything is an
opposite you couldn't have an in without
a note or an up without a down or a hot
without a cold
every positive has a negative so every
problem has an opportunity
now the truth is there's no such thing
as problems or opportunities everything
just is it's how we look at it it is
what it is that's it
now if we see something bad why don't we
say hold on a minute it's my perception
that's messed up here if i stare at this
long enough i'm going to see what's good
in it there has to be good in it you
couldn't have an insight to a room
without having an outside couldn't
possibly have up without heaven down
that's just the law
of polarity it degrees everything has an
opposite i don't care what you look at
there's an option you see something
really good it's also real bad now think
of this if it's only a short way up onto
my desk it's only a short way down off
my desk if it's a long way to the top
it's a long ways to the bottom you can't
have a long way up and a short way down
it doesn't work that way they're equal
and opposite if it's very good it's very
bad if it's very bad it's very good so
you've got a big problem get excited you
got a big opportunity i think we should
be thinking about the uh
the greatness like it's uh the school of
greatness i think we ought to be
thinking about the greatness that we've
lost got locked up within us and bring
it to the surface everyone has deep
reservoirs of talent and ability within
them
and they can bring it to the surface to
accomplish anything they want
now to sit in fear
and wonder what's going to happen
that is a dumb waste of your talent and
your time yeah
and unfortunately
that's what most of the media is uh
promoting right now
to believe in
fear
is to believe in something you can't see
to believe in faith is to believe in
something you can't see well if you have
a choice i think i choose faith over
fear absolutely
i think i believe where i can really see
something happen i believe we're going
to have a phenomenal year in our company
in fact our
i am business partner sandy gallagher
and very bright lady was a securities
attorney prior to joining us
she ran a program this morning for
our entire company we had about 70
people
in the company she was teaching
masterminding to them all
and saying how this is important that
every one of us get involved in this
that we learn the basics of
masterminding that napoleon hill
uh
brought to the world
let's
say way back in the 30s
now i think that's what we should be
teaching people
uh sandy was on the right track there so
i think we ought to be thinking about
what we're going to build how big are we
going to do it where are we going to do
it when are we going to start
our goals have not changed
they're very big they're very ambitious
and we're not letting this virus slow us
down one bit yeah as a matter of fact
we're trying to figure out how can we
use this to speed it up mm-hmm
you can't you can't get rid of it
use it your advantage yeah there is a
way we can use it to our advantage
people are more dependent upon the phone
uh i've got a computer here they're
dependent on their phone their computer
more than they've ever been
we can reach them anywhere in the world
through those mating now carnegie said
to hill
he said now napoleon
[Music]
i'm going to introduce you
to some of the world's most successful
people
he's i'm going to give you letters of
introduction you'll receive no subsidy
from me
i want you to go out and write
the laws of achievement he says it's a
shame that people like myself are going
to their grave with all this knowledge
locked up in their bones he's i want it
organized
and i want you to organize it
i will give you letters of
introduction and then you're on your own
now he said you're going to run into
many tough times napoleon no question
about that
so i said i'm going to give you
something
that'll help you through those tough
times
i want you to write this out i don't
want you to write every word no one's
going to underline every word
now he said
this is a message that you're going to
give
from yourself to yourself napoleon
so it's going to be you talking to you
i want you to write down andrew carnegie
i'm not only going to equal your
achievements in life
i'm going to meet you at the post and
pass you at the grandstand
well
as the story goes he threw his pencil on
the floor he says now you know darn well
i'm not going to be able to do that
he says i know you're not napoleon
unless and until you believe it
but i want you to repeat that every
morning and i want you to repeat it
every night i want you to look in the
mirror and i want you to repeat that
looking in your eyes say andrew carnegie
i'm not only going to equal your
achievements in life i'm going to meet
you at the post and i'm going to pass
you at the grandstand
now that wasn't an easy thing for hill
to do he was living with his brother
he had promised his brother that he was
going to pay for him to go through
college
now he was going to have to go home and
tell his brother he couldn't do that he
or the project that he was working on he
was going to take all his time and was
going to take every cent that he could
get for himself
then he was afraid to tell his brother
what he was going to do because he
thought his brother would think he had
lost his mind he's going to work on a
20-year project nobody's giving him any
money nobody's going to pay him
the first day he went he locked himself
in the bathroom
and he looked in the mirror and he
whispered
and your cardigan
i'm not the only guy to equal your
achievements
in life
i'm going to need you at the post and
i'm gonna pass you the grandstand
you know he said he felt when he was
saying like he was a darn fool
because this isn't gonna happen
but he said i made a commitment that i
would do this so i better do it
so every morning and every night he
would do this now he had committed that
he would do it for 30 days
[Music]
around the middle of the month
he started to think maybe it could
happen
by the end of the month he knew it would
happen
now i've done a fair amount of study in
this over the last 50 years
and
anything i've been able to discover is
that carnegie made somewhere in the
vicinity of 50 millionaires some people
say 20. i've read 23 i've read 50.
napoleon hill has made millions of
millionaires
so you see he did equal his achievements
he went past his achievements and he did
pass him at the grandstand
here's a boy boy a young boy a young cub
reporter for a magazine
how did he do that why did he do that
i think he did it strictly on the belief
that carnegie wasn't going to ask him to
do anything that was unjust
but why is it that all successful people
make decisions very fast and change them
slow and he found out that was true in
his research
with all these giants
well you know i have never stopped
studying it
[Music]
i probably never will stop studying it
and i'm going to show you something
about decision
that has the potential to change your
life forever
you see i wanted to know why do
successful people make decisions when
they have absolutely no idea how they're
going to make it happen
there's a reason for it
now many of them are unconscious
competence they don't know why they do
that's just the way they do it
you can become a conscious competent
that's what i'm going to show you
and you see it all starts with our own
thinking
[Music]
see vibration is the law of the universe
everything vibrates nothing
rests look at the walls around you
they're vibrating they appear to be
still they're really not still look at
them through a microscope you'll see the
energy dancing in front of your eyes
go take a look at a body in a coffin now
you'll think i'm really losing it here
but listen and think
look at the body throw microscope it is
not dead that body's moving it's moving
so fast it appears to be still
and if it wasn't moving how would it
ever change the dust
everything moves we live in an ocean of
motion make no mistake about it
every level of vibration is referred to
as a frequency and a beautiful truth is
we think on frequencies
do you know that every great leader that
has ever lived
every one of them they've been in
complete unanimous agreement on one
point they've disagreed on virtually
everything else but this one point
they've been in agreement on
that we become what we think about
solomon put it very well he was a pretty
bright guy he said as a person thinketh
in their heart it's not just the
thoughts that are running across the
screen of your conscious minds it's the
ones you internalize
we truly do become what we think about
see the thoughts that we're thinking
produce the results that we're getting
the law of rhythm is a lala uh we have a
biorhythm we go up and down we live
simultaneously on three planes we're
triune beings we're spiritual
intellectual and physical
well all three is on a rhythm
cycle
and we have critical highs and critical
lows that's when all three parts of us
are on a critical high
all three parts of us on a very low
do you know there's airlines that will
not let their pilots fly when they're on
a critical low they won't let them fly
they just ground them
you can have this charted i have people
come up and ask me questions sometimes i
know what they want to do they want to
chart my rhythm cycle and i give them
the dates and the things they want but
when they bring it to me i don't pay any
attention to it i don't want to know
that i'm on a low swing
i want to know that i am in control of
me and i don't care whether i'm on a low
swing or a high swing i don't make it
good because i'm going to look for the
good in it
so we understand that there's that time
of the month you know
that's not just for the girls that's for
the boys too because that is a rhythm
cycle in life and it affects all three
parts there's going to be parts when
you're on a very high intellectually you
have a column of figures room like that
you add them up another time you add up
that column you have to add it up six
times you get a net answer every time
you're on the low swing intellectually
there's sometimes when you're on a low
swing emotionally you walk down the
street and nothing's going right there's
other days you walk down you're skipping
with the kids you're singing with the
birds you're on a high
that's a rhythm process of life how do
we reshape our self-image to serve us as
opposed to bring us down
well
it's interesting malts
maxwell malts actually discovered
self-image as we know it today
he was a cosmetic surgeon
and he found
if he operated on a person maybe he had
a distasteful scar in their face
and he removed the scar
he said
sometimes there was a phenomenal change
in the person's personality
but he said other times they'd remove
the scar who's very successful no change
in their personality
that led him to postulate that we not
only have this physical image that
reflects back from the mirror
we have an inner image of ourselves
it's how we see ourself
now that inner image is an idea
and that idea is generally
planted
in our little life when we're infants
and it's planted by virtue of the the
environment that we're surrounded by
how we're raised if a child is raised
with praise they're going to grow up
very confident individuals if a child is
raised with criticism they're going to
grow up very insecure
so you see this image that we have it's
a picture of how we see ourself
but most of us
that image was planted by people that
didn't know what the hell was going on
they didn't know the war was over and
they were planting they were developing
a little mind
it was a mind they were shaping it like
fresh clay they didn't understand that
it was a kid they're looking after and
we feed them we keep them warm what the
hell you know that's our responsibility
no it was a mind and they were
developing that mind and if they didn't
understand what were they going to put
in well all they could give to the child
is the insecurities that they had
themselves
so that was the picture that the kid
grows up of themselves
now i grew up very insecure
i was born during the depression when i
first went to school the second world
war had just broken out so everybody's
rationed for everything it was hard
times all the men were away fighting in
europe or south pacific there was no men
doing it the women that were there were
driving the trucks they were cops they
did everything so it wasn't a whole lot
of time
used for developing a little mind
so i just grew up and
picked up what i could
i grew up very insecure it wasn't until
i met a man that gave me this book and
gave me some damn good instruction that
i started to pay attention to who i was
and
i have never stopped
being fascinated
with studying me yeah
i i am the most fascinating subject
that i've ever come across
and i have found out that you and i are
exactly the same
we only appear to be different
our physical body looks different we
choose different vocations some earns
more or less than the other
but our potential is exactly the same we
both live in a physical body
we both have these higher mental
faculties
we're both spiritual beings we both
drawn an infinite source of supply
we're the same
so the trick i think
for the person that has insecurities
that hasn't got the strongest image they
want
they should find a damn good mentor
that's what changed my life first of all
the cause of fear is ignorance
that is the cause of fear
and so if you follow the ignorance it
doesn't start out as fear
the ignorance starts out in a conscious
level as doubt and worry
that's on a conscious level we're
doubting or we're worrying then we take
whatever image comes into our
consciousness of the doubt the worry and
we turn it over to our emotional mind
that's what causes the fear
well that fear then has to be expressed
through the body to the only instrument
it can be expressed through our physical
body it sets up a vibration known as
anxiety
anxiety is not expressed anxiety becomes
suppressed we suppress it
and the suppression then turns to
depression
which turns to disease which turns to
decay you see you're talking about a
track a person gets on it's a very
negative track
it's ignorance
don't worry
fear
anxiety suppression depression disease
disintegration
now the polar opposite of all that
the opposite of ignorance is knowledge
hmm
there's only one way to get to knowledge
and that is to study
now unfortunately
school
didn't do the job that it was designed
to do for most of us
schools should teach us to love to study
um
not to dread studying and homework and
tests
they should teach us to love it because
study leads to the opposite of don't
worry which is understanding
see it's study that leads to
understanding we understand how to
handle the fear
it's understanding
that enables us to cause us to
understand where the fear starts
the understanding
then
we want to say what do we understand we
want to understand this whole universe
operates by law
one of the laws is the law of opposite
the opposite of don't worry is
understanding
now if the don't worry leads to fear
what's understanding leads to
understanding leads to faith
the faith leads to
expression
well-being
and expression
it's not depression
it's not suppression it's not anxiety
the faith leads to well-being
the well-being then is expression
acceleration because we're at ease we're
not at there's not disease so you're
dealing with polar opposites there's two
different sides to things
and when we understand that
our world starts to change
it's by understanding that that we learn
how to deal with these
pandemics when they hit
and they will hit there will be others
there always has been all down through
history if you look back
there's been things like this happen in
the past
and unfortunately the masses are sort of
paralyzed by it no amount of reading or
memorizing is going to make you
successful
it's the understanding and application
of why something
you're going to study this
i study it every day
every day
for at least an hour
sometimes more but at least an hour
it's a habit
habit something you do unconsciously you
don't even spend any time thinking about
it you just do it
you get dressed by habit
you shower comb wash your hair
habit
do you know good habits
automatically transform our life the
purpose of a goal is not to get
it's not to reach the goal it's the
awareness that you develop as you go
after it
you're learning who you are
it's becoming aware of who you are
yeah
i was in a seminar years and years ago
and there was a speaker bill gove
bill gove
was considered the
frank sinatra public speakers he was
incredible
he had a handheld mic
and he's looking at the audience and he
said
if i want to be free
i've got to be me
not to me i think you think i should be
not to me i think my kids think i should
be
not to me i think my wife thinks i
should be if i want to be free
i've got to be me
he said i better know who me is we do
live in an ocean emotion
the dynamic law of life is create or
disintegrate you're never going to stay
where you are following what we're
teaching
you're going to create
it's a beautiful part
so we're looking at our results and
we're saying but this is where i really
want to go and we point to a star that
we're shooting at and we make a decision
that's what i'm gonna do
unfortunately
everybody does that
and 90 some percent say when this
improves then i'm gonna do that do you
know
it'll never happen
it will never happen
because you're not on the right
frequency and you see what happens here
pretty soon the decision fades
and when it fades
so does the goal the goal disappears
somebody said i thought you were working
yeah well i am i'm still working at it
do you know what the problem is
you're thinking on the wrong frequency
you see your thought is down here on the
frequency that you're living on
but the way to do what you want to do is
not on that frequency
clearly understand this all science and
all theology the only two sources of
reference we have to go to tell us
nothing is created or destroyed
the way to do anything is already here
space travel we've always been able to
do it we just weren't aware of how
[Music]
you know the neat little cell phones
we've got that pretty soon will be
obsolete
we've always been able to do that
i remember back we had the party lines
hardly anybody had a phone then when
they got one they got a party line
everybody's on the line
we were able to build
beautiful little cell phones then
do you know the cell phone you've got
has more power as a computer
than the computer that took the first
rocket to the moon it's
magnificent when you think of what we're
doing it's all an awareness and that's
what you're developing you're developing
awareness
see the awareness to do everything is
already here but you've got to get on
the frequency that it operates on
because everything operates on a
frequency
if you phoned your uncle harry you
wouldn't expect your mother to answer
the phone
why because you dialed harry's number
you got on harry's frequency that's what
the number is it's a frequency
and there's a zillion of them we know
there's an infinite number of
frequencies
everything you want is already here
what you have to do is subtract it
and you know something you're going to
learn how to do that
you see
what we really have to do we need to
make a paradigm shift we're programmed
to operate the way we're operating why
would 97 or 95 of the population keep
using a losing formula
they don't know they are
they're giving it everything they've
done we to shift
our thinking
we're going to shift the paradigm do you
know many of the beliefs and the ideas
that are controlling your
decision-making right now
they were established by some great
grandparent who lived in a different
time but all that stuff is passed down
in the genes
it's called genetic conditioning we had
to change that you see well you're
thinking way down here on this lower
frequency
the way to do what you want to do
is a way up here on a higher frequency
and what's required
is a committed decision
committed decision
is when you do it regardless
and when you make a committed decision
this is what i'm going to do
you flip your brain onto that higher
frequency
and the way is
shown now we're going to talk about your
sixth sense
your intuitive mind because that's how
it comes to you you're tapping into
universal intelligence
that's what all highly successful people
do whether they know they're doing it or
not is irrelevant but that's what
they're doing that's what you're going
to learn how to do it because it's true
i think reason is probably
it's the one that's spoken about by
almost all the great leaders yeah
they've all been complete
agreement that we become what we think
about
it's our reasoning factor that enables
us to think
um
ford says thinking's the hardest work
there is which is the probable reason so
few people engage in it
dr ken mcfarland
is gone for a long time now but he was a
great educator down in kentucky he one
time said two percent of the people
think three percent think they think and
95 would actually rather die than things
now you know that sounds cute
but it's true
if you stop and listen
to what most people are saying
it's going to be fairly obvious they're
not thinking if you stand back and watch
what most people are doing
it's fairly obvious they're not thinking
or they would never say or do what
they're doing
most people today have their television
on the news
and they're just
soaking up
all the stuff
that's going on that's dominating the
media right now
so they've become a play thing for
what's going on outside
and that's why they're living in such
fear
by consuming the media of whether it's
true or accurate or not true you're
you're being manipulated
yeah it's not a matter of whether it's
true or not
is this how you want to spend your life
just listening to that
um
that doesn't mean you should deny it it
doesn't mean that you should say well
that's all false
um
i don't know whether it's true or false
it's just bad news i don't want to be
involved in it yeah am i aware that it's
there well you'd almost have to be dead
not to be aware that it's there but that
doesn't mean you have to spend your time
thinking on that
i would much rather activate some of my
creative faculties and
do something that's constructive we are
building a picture
in our mind here this is an idea
we could say it's a
goal then we impress that idea upon this
part of our personality
that's the idea in our mind
now what we've got to understand
is that
this part of our mind the subject of
mind
is actually universal intelligence
and this is really the way it is
when you press the id upon your
subconscious mind
you are
universally everywhere
now to help you think of that
where here's the phone
let's suppose you're in uh
i don't know
buenos aires
and
i'm right here
in north america toronto
and i dial your number i've got you on
the phone
time and space means nothing because
i've got on to that frequency
and so you and i can communicate
we're connected
one person's in buenos aires or you
could say singapore you could say
shanghai and another one is in new york
or in toronto but they're connected why
the time and space means nothing
because you're dealing with energy
and you're dealing with laws
now when you impress this idea upon the
subconscious mind
the subconscious mind is universal
intelligence
and everything
anywhere in the universe
that's in harmony
that is a frequency understand that
that idea is a frequency
it's operating on a frequency
and so everything that's in harmony with
it
begins to move toward it
because then harmonious vibration and
you attract it
now
throw a slide up scott
look here for a moment
soren
kiekergaard wrote something really great
on intuition
he said
listen you got to listen you listen with
your emotions
we can only get in touch with our own
source of intuition and wisdom
when we no longer depend upon others
opinions for our sense of identity or
worth
we all tend to worship something
the question is will we worship the god
of opinion
or the god of our heart
i found i had less and less to say until
finally
i became silent
and began to listen
i discovered in the silence
the voice of god
now look it
you're going to attract to you
everything that you require
to manifest the idea in your mind
thoughts will come to you
it's your intuition that picks them up
and then act on them
and just because you've never gone there
before you've never done it before
that's okay
this is where courage comes in
this is where awareness
and wisdom comes in
see intuition is the mental faculty
if go back to our slide here for a
moment scott
intuition is here
in our conscious mind
it's one of our intellectual factors
we have perception
the will
reason
imagination
memory
and
intuition
right here
now intuition is that mental faculty on
a conscious level
we pick up thoughts
that are flying our way
they're flying our way
what are they
it's energy that's in harmony with you
you've got on the frequency
of this good that you desire
and you're going to start attracting and
that's what kierkegaard said we got to
start listening
we listen with our emotions let's pay
attention to what's coming our way i
didn't like the idea that
when you've lived for so long you've got
to cut out you've got to stop i thought
hell i don't like that idea at all
um
first of all i think we're
we're i believe we're here to do god's
work god's work is creation
you know
uh
expansion fuller expression greater
goodness
um
and if we're going to do that
we're going to be working at it
all the time we're here on this planet
we never stop so age should have no
bearing on it mm-hmm
i had a gospel of peace
to build this place we
put a couple of million dollars into
this and somebody said how old are you
and i think i was probably 83 when they
started to break ground
they said you're 83 and you're gonna
spend two million dollars building a
studio i said yeah like
why not
i mean
you see we let things that
really have no concern we let them
bother us we let them control us
age is a dumb thing to let control you
it's our thinking that controls
everything
that's the one point every great leader
agreed on we become what we think about
well what's a person thinking
i'm thinking if i get old i got to stop
well then you'll stop
or i'm thinking well if i've been here a
long time i've got a lot of experience i
want to utilize that experience to keep
me going as long as i am here you know
don schuler the coach of the old my
miami dolphins
he said it's the start that stops most
people and he's right it is the start
that stops most people they're always
going to get ready to get set to get
going what we've got to do is boom just
like that move into action
see if you don't get started you're
never going to get finished
how do we do that
start early
i believe when you wake up you should
get up the second you wake up get your
feet hit the floor move into action
and you know you'd be wise if you sit
down at night before you go to bed and
write down
six goal achieving activities
now that doesn't go to the store
go to the bank or
get to cleaning it's not that these are
goal achieving activities write down six
of them
and when you wake up in the morning you
move into action you know where you're
going to go you don't even have to think
about it
step into action and get on the first
one
when you get it done forget it and go to
the second one
don't think about the first one focus on
two don't even think about three when
you get two done go to three
but knock them off one at a time if you
don't get them all done just move them
over onto the next day
and that doesn't mean if you only get
three done that you have nine the next
day
there are three of the six that you're
going to do the next day
six goal achieving activities and when
you wake up in the morning move into
action on them quit holding yourself
back don't wait
and say well i really don't know how i'm
going to get started and the way will
show itself it just appears
i have found when you get started when
you move into action everything starts
to happen around you
now fill in the card get the information
i have worked all over the world i mean
all over asia china south america and
north america europe
and i'm always asking people what do you
really want
and i have found
most people don't want to be really
wealthy
what they do want is they don't want to
have any financial concerns
if they want to buy a new suit they can
go and get one if they want to take a
trip they can take the trip
if they
want a new car they can get the new car
they don't want to just run out and
spend or buy
they don't want to have any financial
concerns
two
they want to wake up in the morning
excited about how they're going to spend
their day
and the third
they want to mix with people
who are upbeat
and
creatively productive
these are the three things that people
really want
so in answer to your question if
somebody's watching
what's the first thing they should do
well
the first thing they should do is
understand why we have goals
not just to set a goal because most
people don't set goals right
they they're operating with a limited
level of consciousness so they're
thinking
hmm
if i
could get a little more money and if i
could get him to help me and her to help
me and this happened then i could do
this
maybe this is get a new car
what we've got to understand is we're
trading our life for our goals
literally trading our life
would you trade your life for a car
or a house i don't think so
so it's got to be something really
meaningful
and we're not taught to think this way
we should sit down
and don't give any thought to where the
money is going to come from where the
help's going to come from it's what do
you really want
like ed hillary was a beekeeper in
auckland
that story
he wanted to climb mount everest it had
never been done good people died trying
to do it
he went in 51 and failed he went back in
52 and failed
in 1953 he stood on top of the mountain
with tenzing norgay
but he didn't know how to get there
until after he had got there
edison didn't know how to illuminate the
world until after he had done it
the wright brothers were bicycle
mechanics in dayton ohio
no one believed you could fly
they had been trying it for years
but they saw it
but they wanted to do it
they didn't know how
and they couldn't tell you until after
they had done it
now the first flight only lasted 12
seconds
and the naysayers said yeah but they
only were up there for 12 seconds they
said we not only got up there we kept
the damn thing up there for 12 seconds
so when a person sets a goal
they've got to say
what could i want
if i just let my mind rock just wander
visions
pictures that we build in our mind
most people don't use their imagination
constructively most people use their
imagination destructively they imagine
what they don't want
we've got to consciously and
deliberately imagine what we do want
if we will take and sit down with a pen
and ask ourself what do i really want
what do i really want
and write it down
and then
make a written description of it in the
present tense
writing causes thinking thinking creates
an image
and you get these images going you're
building a vision in your mind
it's the visionaries that's changed the
world think of that
the fact that i can sit and look into
this camera
and you can sit and look at me on your
phone
or on your
tv or on your laptop
that was the result of somebody's vision
do you know everything you've got the
clothes you wear the house you live in
this microphone that's in front of me
it was all a result of somebody's vision
it's not an accident
you and i have a marvelous imagination
and everything starts
with a vision select the person who is
already doing something that you'd like
to do get to know that person
go to the experts for advice don't ask
the person next door your mother father
or brother or the guy that works beside
you
because they don't necessarily know
there's no point in asking a person how
to earn a lot of money if they're only
earning 10 000 a year they don't know
they knew they'd probably be earning a
lot
it's like don't go to a sick doctor if
you want to get healthy okay so you find
someone that you can go to for advice
get a real good book and lock into that
book and start to study it like
i've had this one that looks like a
bible you know
but this is napoleon hill's book think
and grow rich i've been reading this
thing now for 23 years
i'll probably read it for another 23
years i get another good book that i
brought over here today it's called the
power of your subconscious mind
and i'm not getting the commission for
selling this the author's
dead now he's been gone for a couple of
years but dr joseph murphy wrote this
book the power of your subconscious mind
and that's probably one of the best
books that you're ever going to find
because you're going to learn something
about your mind when you read this book
okay now i read a lot of books i've got
probably a thousand bucks sitting in my
den at home in my library but the one
that i care i carry it everywhere i go
and i read it all the time is think and
grow rich i never stop reading it now
where's the value for you to re-read
that and read it i mean you must you
must know it well enough that uh i think
i could probably recite it verbatim but
the secret is i once read in a book
where it said when you read a good book
through
the second time
you don't see something in it that you
didn't see before you see something in
yourself that wasn't there before you
see when i read this i created a greater
awareness you know many years ago i read
a book by terry cole whitaker it was a
classic what you think of me is none of
my business
think of the amount of time that is
wasted on negative energy wondering what
other people think of you
what they think of you really doesn't
make any difference it's what you think
of you that makes a difference so as you
go through the day
don't
worry about what other people think of
you
just say
i'm all right i'm god's highest form of
creation see this line
that's called the terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it
and on the other side of the terror
barrier is something we call freedom
and you know
very few people get through that terror
barrier it's rather sad
freedom is available to everyone
there isn't anyone
that cannot live the way they want to
live
see
why don't they
why don't they
they don't know
and they don't even know they don't know
now i'm going to show you
why people experience buyer's remorse
when they buy something they really want
and then they back away
where they go to move and they don't
they go to change jobs they don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't lie
fear
causes them to stay where they are
there's the individual the x represents
the unknown factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of what they want remember
we said we have the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the paradigm
now here's an important point
the paradigm controls the vibration of
this thing we call our body our body is
a molecular instrument that's really
what it is it's a mass of molecules and
a very high speed of vibration
the vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now
they choose thoughts
that harmonize with the vibration
they're in so they feel comfortable they
may not like the results but they're
comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look
here those people are getting x-type
results and they don't like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison and walk out into
freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage
now let's go ahead here's the same
person
x type conditioning x type vibration
the power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from left
field boom in comes a y type idea what
is the y type idea the y type idea
represents anything that you might want
to do that you're not doing
it might be moved to another city change
jobs
sell the house buy the farm whatever it
may be
ask the little girl for the date
ask the guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the y
idea but as long as the y idea is just
in the conscious mind it's just going to
be an intellectual exercise it's never
going to happen
so how do we make it happen
well
that's when
everything goes haywire here we are here
same person okay the power flows in
and what do they do they got the y type
idea
now for some strange reason they know
that they've got to get emotionally
involved that they're going to act on
that idea they don't understand what's
going to happen but clearly understand
this
your central nervous system is the most
complex electrical system in the
universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling it would make the
electrical system and a super computer
look like a toy
now the second you take the idea from
your intellect and impress it upon the
subject of mind that's when all hell
breaks loose
because the body moves in to an extra xy
vibration it's not in the x vibration
not the one that we're comfortable with
may not like the results but we're
comfortable
no on a conscious level everything's
going crazy on a conscious level we
experience doubt the doubt turns into an
emotion called fear and that fear is
expressed through the body as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like
at least they're comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that terror
barrier
see the terror barrier is going beyond
where you're at going to a new level
i'm going to tell you something when i
set a goal
if if if it doesn't scare and excite me
at the same time i know i'm going in the
wrong direction
now i also understand
that my paradigm is going to try and get
me to bounce back to where i was it
doesn't want me to move ahead
i don't want to live there
i lived there for the first 26 years of
my life and for the last 50 i've had a
phenomenal life and it just keeps
getting better and i want you to do the
same thing understand what i've just
said i'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the y
idea
that moved their body into a different
vibration on a conscious level they're
experiencing some crazy stuff they start
to doubt their ability will never be
able to pay for it they experience fear
the fear expresses itself as anxiety
and bang you bounce off that terror
barrier and you're right back
oh i might not be earning much hair but
i know what it is
i i would love to move there but i'm
comfortable here i think i'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't do you know what to do say i'm
going to get rid of all that i
understand it's there but i don't want
any part of it and i'm going to go
crashing right through that terror
barrier
now does that get rid of the x energy no
the x energy
is still there
you see but at least you're over into
freedom you made the move you did it and
if you continue to feed the right
information into your mind keep feeding
that y idea keep getting emotionally
involved in the y idea you're there
you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know where you're living
in freedom you're living where you want
to live
buyer's remorse
is when you cancel the sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that
and if you don't learn to go through the
terror barrier i'm going to tell you
something you're going to stay right
where you are
for the rest of your days that's not a
good place to be
what did joseph campbell say
so true
the cave you fear to enter
holds the treasure you seek you know dr
maxwell mulch wrote a book back around
1960
it was called self-image psychology
psycho-cybernetics it's a phenomenal
book
he said it was the greatest discovery of
his generation
he was a cosmetic or a reconstructive
surgeon and he found he would do work on
people he might have
done a nose job or removed a terrible
scar
and he noticed that when he did that
there was a phenomenal change in their
personality but he noticed with others
he would make a phenomenal physical
change and there was no change in their
personality and that led him to
postulate that we have two images we
have the one that's coming back from the
mirror but we've got an inner image and
that inner self-image is literally
controlling our life
you will find people that have a very
poor self-image or low self-esteem they
won't look you straight in the eye
they're afraid to shake hands with you
they're very shy and withdrawn they go
through life hiding from life
they don't like themselves
they don't know themselves
do you know when a person improves their
self-image they change their entire life
their income change their relationship
change their health changes
and you know how you do that
start studying you start to find out
more about you
there's something phenomenal about you
do you know when i began to study this
material
57 years ago
i had very poor self-image i had low
self-esteem
i took dumb jobs i never earned any
money i never had fun i had poor
relationships and as i started to study
started to study real solid information
everything in my life started to improve
i've got friends all over the world
today i earn millions of dollars
i'm in my 80s and i get as much energy
as a person in their 30s
you see
when you start to understand really who
you are you're god's highest form of
creation there's things about you that
just about blow your mind as you start
to study and really understand them
you'll walk a little taller you'll stand
a little straighter and you know
something you'll enjoy a whole lot more
of life you've got to wake up
you see
all we're ever going to get is awareness
we've already got everything
the only thing we lack is the awareness
of what we've got we're god's highest
form of creation there's nothing on the
planet that will equal us
well
that's all we're that's all any of us
are after all the problems in the world
come from ignorance
that's the purpose of life overcome
ignorance
develop awareness the only way to
overcome ignorance is through knowledge
and the only way to get the knowledge is
to study
most people they finish school close the
book saying i got it that's over i'm
never going to open another book as long
as i live
they're screwed it's all over do you
know the people you surround yourself
with have a phenomenal impact on your
life
i think it was karl meniger from the
medicare foundation one time said
environment is more important than
heredity
the people we're surrounded by have a
greater bearing on our life and our
success in life
than what's built into the genes at
birth there's genetic conditioning
there's environmental conditioning well
this environmental conditioning goes on
all the way through life
you will find as you improve the quality
of your life improve your thinking
you're going to attract a different
group of people into your life and they
are going to add to your life
[Music]
see the people we're surrounded by
their thinking is going right into our
mind
[Music]
we want to mix with people who are
really making it happen take a look at
your five people that you're with most
often
and ask yourself
if i have children would i want them to
grow up be like them
if the answer is no
you better start looking for some new
friends if the answer is yes you're
already in the right circle of people
think about what i'm saying
the people we're surrounded with have a
phenomenal impact on our life and help
make us who we are william james from
harvard said believe and your belief
will create the fact
all things are possible if you believe
well you know i studied for a long time
i started to study this book think and
grow rich
and he talks about belief in here he
says you're not ready for what you want
until you believe you can get it
i found that the
only two sources of reference we could
go to to find out anything about
yourself is science and religion
they all say you've got to believe
so i get figured out
how do you how do you believe
how do you change a belief
interesting subject because i'm going to
tell you something
your results are nothing but the
manifestation of your belief system
well our belief system now listening
carefully is based upon our evaluation
of something and frequently when we
reevaluate a situation our belief about
that situation will change
let me repeat that
our belief system is based upon our
evaluation of something
frequently if we re-evaluate a situation
our belief about it will change
i began reevaluating who i was i started
to study i never stopped studying and i
found as i reevaluated i had a much
higher opinion of myself i found out
things about me that i would have never
believed if you had told me the power
that's locked up within us the marvelous
system we've got you know the blood
circulates through your veins every 33
seconds through hundreds of miles of
passageway bang just like that colors
all the food in and all the garbage out
just have to think of the central
nervous system it's the most complex
electrical system in the world
and you've got it
think of your brain an electronic
switching station like that you can
change the vibration of yourself and
everything around you
we have awesome powers and it's all
based on what you believe about you i
don't think you determine what your
purpose is i think you discover what
your purpose is there's a difference
determining
indicates deciding
um
and i don't think you decide i think if
you go about it the right way you
discover it
like there's some people that should be
painting
all day
they're great artists
i think michelangelo was obviously a
great artist great sculptor
i mean
that was his purpose
in his life
well
i believe my purpose
is doing what i'm doing
your purpose is why you get out of bed
in the morning do you know why you get
up well most people say well it's to go
to work well that'd be a good reason to
stay in bed you know
you say well everybody's doing it to be
another reason to stay in bed if you're
ever doing what everybody's doing you're
probably going in the wrong direction
your purpose is your reason for living
what you want to do is sit down
and maybe
take a pen and a pad
and then ask yourself what do i really
love doing now you may have to spend a
while at this
you might get up an hour early every
morning
and
go sit under a tree somewhere if you're
in a nice climate
or pick a favorite chair someplace where
you're not going to be disturbed
and totally relax
and say
if i could spend my life doing something
what do i really love doing
now since you don't ask yourself that
question every day it might take a while
for this answer to come to the surface
but it comes
to your consciousness
and it may take a while you may have to
do this every morning for
three months
but it would be
well invested how many times have you
had somebody say to you hey have you got
a minute bomb
have you got a minute
they don't want a minute
i want you to think about that
i read a poem one time i said i have
only just a minute
only 60 seconds in it it was forced upon
me i can't refuse it i didn't seek it
and i didn't choose it but it's up to me
to use it i must suffer if i lose it
give a count if i abuse it it's only a
tiny little minute but eternity is in
well anyway i thought i'm going to put
this on a video and i'm just going to
share with everybody just this one
little part of the seminar i'm making
i want you to look at this sand timer
and let this i want you to think about
your life the sand in the top of the
glass represents the future
the sand in the bottom of the glass
represents the past
now do you know we know what's in the
past and yet we can't do anything about
it do you know what the trick is you
don't know how much sands in the top of
the glass
you may think you have a lot you might
only have a little
then again you may think you have a
little and you might have a lot
when i was a little boy i was raised by
my grandmother
and i don't know when i was little
gaffer she was probably 60 but
as long as i could remember grandma
would say and i'll soon be glad here
i'll soon be gone well you know we loved
her she was really an angel of god but
we thought she was never going to go she
lived to be 94 for 30 some years i'll
soon be gone
she didn't think she had much time left
she had 34 years left
now about the same time i had a buddy of
mine bob yates he was just 16.
and bang he run into the abutment of a
bridge and his life was snuffed out
if you had asked him a half hour before
how much sandy had left he would have
said at least a half a century he didn't
have a half an hour
see the trick is we don't know how much
sand we have left
the future
we don't know the past it's gone now the
only thing you can deal with is what's
right here right now and if you look the
sand is always moving
now think of this
you see i was working on that and then i
was working on a graph i've got here on
my computer
and i'm thinking of the time somebody
said have you got a minute
well they don't really want a minute
do you know if you're earning fifty
a year in minutes 42 cents
a half hour is
12.50
if we take that ahead a bit if you're
earning 80 000 a year a minute 67 cents
half hour's 20
dollars if you're earning a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars a year got a
minute
it cost you a dollar twenty five a
minute
a half hours thirty seven dollars and
fifty cents so if you see if somebody
said you wanna stop for a cup of coffee
well
if you're earning a quarter of a million
dollars a year
a minute is two dollars and eight cents
half hour is 62.50
and then of course you've got the coffee
to pay for on top of that
so you see
the point is this
this is all we've got right here right
now we don't know how much we have left
in the future but we do know what we've
got now and i have found the people that
win
are the people who make up their mind
they're not going to waste the minutes
they're going to be productive they're
going to make it happen
every minute he said that success was
the progressive realization of a worthy
ideal anyone that has a goal and they're
moving towards it they're successful
most people think that you're successful
if you have a lot of money quite often
you have a lot of money if you're
successful but it isn't i wouldn't say
mother teresa
has a lot of money okay but she's a
pretty successful lady so it's um
okay so that barrier to these well
there's there's a couple of them okay i
think there's two barriers one is our
conditioning the conditioning that takes
place in our subconscious mind from the
time we're infants
all we can do is act and talk like the
people around us that's why we learn the
language we learned if there was 10
languages spoken in our home we'd learn
10 languages without any trouble
there's usually one and that's the only
one we ever learn we grow older and we
think well i couldn't learn another
language we could learn 100 if we wanted
to you can do anything but i think we're
conditioned we have a
real strong conditioning usually with
not some very good ideas
and then that that's the
the barrier that's inside is the one
that's outside of us is our environment
we have a tendency to act like everybody
around us
and if you think about this it doesn't
make a lot of sense because if you study
statistics 95 of the people live their
entire life and never live the way they
want to live
you know that 95 percent of the
population in this country let's say in
north america okay the richest continent
in the history of the world
they'll work productively let's say for
40 of their 65 years okay and they'll
end up with hardly any money
there's got to be something wrong
so there's no five percent of the people
end up financially comfortable or
independent
are you trying to depress this bob
because that's uh no actually i think
it's i think it's quite an exciting idea
because you see the idea behind it is
that anybody can win
anyone at all but if we start studying
these statistics i think we'll arrive at
the conclusion geez i better start
thinking for myself rather than follow
everybody
most people they get a job they look
around they see how everybody else is
doing their work and they start doing it
the same way
they should stop and think i wonder if
any of these people know what they're
doing
is there a better way to do it but don't
we have a need to fit in i mean we don't
want it we don't want to stand out we
don't want to get fired we don't make
waves
exactly exactly just fall into line you
know take a number be like everybody
around
now that'd be great in the animal
kingdom
but human beings aren't supposed to live
that way i think we should make a few
waves
we should maybe stand out be different
not not for the sake of being different
okay but because we are different
we all think different thoughts
and i believe we should start to think
and build images in our mind of what
we'd like to do and then set out and do
it okay emerson did that edison did that
marconi did that and samuel morris did
that uh buck minister fuller did that we
could go on and on and on okay they were
different they stood out they made a few
waves you know napoleon hill in think
and grow rich wrote an entire chapter on
decision
most people never make decisions they
have a difficult time with it why is
that
i think they have a difficult time
because their parents made decisions for
them until they were too old
and they never learned how to make them
you know the one thing that i did with
my kids i never made a decision for them
they didn't like it they'd say come on
don't do that to me i said no what do
you think you should do and i'd leave it
at that
decision making is a phenomenal concept
and you're going to find out as he
points out in here that successful
people make decisions very fast and they
change them very slow if and when they
change them at all and he said the
people that have difficulty in life make
their decisions very slow and then
change them fast and often
and you know decision making is a funny
thing you and i think on frequencies if
we can see a bunch of lines and we're
thinking on a frequency
and we're on this frequency here and
we'll say i'm going to do that
when this changes this is never going to
change until you get up on this
frequency see the good that you're after
is on a higher frequency than you're
operating on a greater awareness and if
you're down here and you're thinking
here on this frequency and the good you
want up here you've got to get your mind
up there how do you get up there make
the decision be there and that's really
what you have to do the second you make
a decision you flip your brain onto a
different frequency and you start to
attract things to you that you couldn't
you'd never get without making the
decision see someone woke me up that's
all i want to do with someone else what
the man said to me the first guy he said
you can have whatever you want
well you know they if you get thinking
that you can get out of the box
that's where you've been given an
imagination to get out of the box it's
with your imagination that you build
images of what you want and if you can
build the image you can do it you can
hold it in your head you can hold it in
your hand
when we understand that
like i would imagine this goes out to a
lot of athletes
well they can they can have anything
they want they got to pay the price
and when doubt comes in kick it out you
can't afford the doubt if i want to do
something
i find somebody that's already done it
and then i do exactly what they tell me
it's a simple rule to follow
i
i don't read novels
i don't watch
movies and
[Music]
i'd watch documentaries or things like
that where i can learn
and
i'm only interested in
studying
something that can cause me to become
more of what i'm capable of being
see i think we're all hardwired to do
something really special with our life
and
that's all i want to do
i'm really good at what i do
i could walk by a person in the hall
like that i could tell them exactly what
they're like i could read their energy
like a book
everything goes on the inside shows on
the outside see
we're gifted with with faculties of the
mind that the average person knows
nothing about you of intuition the will
reason imagination perception
memory
that's what separates us from all the
rest of forms of life
we go through school never learn
anything about it
you'll hear people say they have a bad
memory there's no such thing as a bad
memory everybody has a perfect memory
it's just weak they've never developed
it
our imagination
your imagination is the most magnificent
hill said it's the most marvelous
miraculous inconceivably powerful force
the world's ever known
i can use my imagination to project
myself into the future and bring the
future into the present and start living
there
you work from the imagination you don't
work to it
you work from it backwards from the
result yeah look at these two men
do you know who they are most people
don't they're just a couple of ordinary
guys one they're both gone now but one
was an ordinary beekeeper in auckland
new zealand and the other as sherpa
guide from over around nepal now there's
mount everest do you know for thousands
of years people had tried to get to the
top mount everest people died doing it
it was believed it couldn't be done
people tried but they didn't know how
and so they quit
there's a closer look at the mountain
and where they placed their flag they
planted that flag in the mountain now
this is the two of them after they come
down the mountain and you know something
when they started they did not know how
they didn't know how to get to the top
of the mountain and that's what stops
most people because they don't know how
as little kids we'd go mummy daddy i
want this and they said how are you
going to do that well as a little kid
you don't know how to do it but they did
it in 1953 on the 29th of may they were
the first two to get to the top of that
mountain they stood right on top of the
world
do you know there's been over a thousand
people do it since then i watched a
young woman on canadian television being
interviewed not very big
she'd just come back from going to the
top of mount everest and the reporter
asked her they said how does it feel now
that you conquered the mountain she'd we
didn't conquer the mountain that
mountain can't be conquered we conquered
the limitations that are within
ourselves
many years ago
i read we're in napoleon hill pointed
out that the imagination is the most
marvelous
miraculous
inconceivably powerful force
that the world has ever known
and you know
the average individual uses the
imagination if they use it at all
against themselves they imagine what
they don't want they imagine problems
coming
let's begin to use our imagination the
way god meant it to be used it's the
greatest creative faculty
that we possess
and we can build anything we want with
it
i want you to wander around your home or
possibly your office
and take a look at all of the
conveniences that you have there
that you didn't have
let's say two years five years ten years
ago
25 years ago
do you know that every one of them
without exception was first created
in the mind of one individual
with their imagination
do you know you can use your imagination
to go into the future and bring it into
the
present that's what all highly
successful people do
they see where they want to go
and then they act like the person they
want to become
it was william james from harvard's
advice
he says is the actors technique act like
the person you want to become how do you
do that
well you use your imagination of course
you see it's a strange
phenomena
but the greatest gift we've got
is used
very well
up till the ages of four or possibly
five
the little child
we always wonder what's going on in
their mind they're using their
imagination they're building wonderful
pictures in their mind but then they get
to school and wham like that it comes to
an abrupt halt
it's called not paying attention
daydreaming
well
what they were really doing was
exercising a phenomenal mental faculty
you see
we can see hear smell taste touch
they're for our physical benefit as long
as we're living in a physical body and
corresponding with the material world we
will use our sensory factors
but you know i have a couple of little
dogs at home that can hear see smell
taste and touch
[Music]
we've got higher faculties you have
perception
the will
memory
intuition
reason
and imagination
these
marvelous tools
we can take our imagination and build an
image in our mind of how we want to live
block out what's going now
don't let your present results have
anything to do with this
just what you want
and it's with your imagination that you
will build it
everything that we have the camera that
i'm speaking to right now
was first created in the mind of one
individual
[Music]
think of how our world's changed
you see
we were gifted
with these higher faculties
we're god's highest form of creation
we were created in god's image we were
given creative faculties to use
and you know they're only used by two or
three percent of the population
[Music]
it's almost inconceivable that we people
would wander around with so much power
and potential
and squander it
see the average person literally tiptoes
through life hoping they make it safely
to death
it's such a shame and it doesn't have to
be that way
i think we have giant corporations and
little weak creative departments
the primary reason for that is
the average individual
really does not believe that they're
creative
i think everyone's creative and no one
is more creative than another
it's just that some have chosen to use
their creative faculties to a greater
degree than others
imagination
your imagination
what do you want
how do you really want to live
build the picture in your mind there's a
power
that is flowing to and through you
a creative
unadulterated
power
it can be photographed leaving your body
way back in the 30s simeon curling the
russian photographer
perfected a form of photography where
you can actually photograph a person's
body and you will see the energy glowing
from them
well that energy flows into your mind
and it's the images you build in your
mind that's going to dictate the
vibration that this instrument you're
living in is in
and the vibration on a conscious level
is called feeling
make certain that you exercise your
imagination daily build beautiful images
in your mind of how you want to live and
then hold those pictures there and live
that way
the
imagination the greatest nation in the
world
the imagination
you've got one
it's a marvelous creative tool
it deals with the invisible side of your
personality
you see no one will ever really see you
they'll only see your body and they'll
see you the great work that you do
make certain that your work is great
work
and if you keep your imagination alive
keep it active
you're going to have a phenomenal life
you know life can get better every day
and it will get better every day
through the proper use
of your
imagination
what a wonderful idea
is bob proctor thank you
you know that the law of attraction is
always working it's like the law of
gravity if i let this go it's going to
go down it's never going to go back up
it's going to go down that is the law of
gravity anything heavier than earth is
attracted towards the center of the
world well the law of attraction is
always working
now how does it work
well
i use a diagram to explain the mind now
let this circle represent your mind
and let this little circle here
represent your body
now i want you to think of this for a
moment
your body is a molecular structure this
is a massive energy and a very high
speed of vibration
if you looked at your body through a
microscope you'd see that energy dancing
right before your eyes and here's
something that'll keep you thinking for
the next 20 years when you move out of
it the body does not stop moving if you
go to a funeral parlor and pick up the
remains and look at it you will see it
moving and if it wasn't moving how would
it ever change the dust
you move into your body and you will
move up
and it's how you use your mind that's
going to dictate the vibration you're in
now stay with me
you have an imaginary line right across
here
and that separates the conscious mind
from the subconscious mind
now this subconscious mind has been
programmed
when you were a little baby this is the
way it was so just like this
subconscious mind wide open and
everything that was going on around it
went right in there
and all the energy that went in there
when you were just a little baby form
something called a paradigm
now a paradigm
is information it's a multitude of
habits you are the product of your
environment but prior to that you are
the product of a genetic strain that
goes back for generations now i'm going
to say that the paradigm is x type
energy
now you've got the ability here on a
conscious level to think
and you can think anything you want to
think
and as you think you build ideas
there's a power that's flowing into your
consciousness it never stops it flows to
and through you you can actually
photograph this power leaving you it
flows to and through you
now as it flows in you will start
thinking and you'll probably think x
type thoughts
therefore you're going to be in an x
type vibration
and that will produce
x type results now it's the results you
want to change
and to change the results you're going
to have to change what you attract
you see the thoughts that you think
control the vibration that you're in
vibration is nothing but an idea it's a
law of the universe everything vibrates
nothing rests we live in a notion of
motion
and it's the thoughts that you're
thinking that you impress upon your
subconscious mind that control the
vibration the body's in and that
dictates how you act but it also
dictates what you attract
you attract energy that's in harmony
with you you attract people that are in
harmony with you you see everything
operates on frequencies there's an
infinite number of frequencies but you
and i operate on a frequency just like a
radio station does and the only music
you can attract is the music that is
tuned in to the vibration you're in
now it's the paradigm that has been
controlling the vibration you can change
your thinking
but that doesn't do anything you got to
change the paradigm
and if you don't change the paradigm
nothing happens
now talking about paradigms is another
subject we'll do that at another time
but it's the thoughts that you think
that control the vibration you're in and
that dictates what you attract so if you
keep attracting what you don't want
understand this
it's the paradigm that's causing the
problem you can think a y type thought
which is totally different than the x
type conditioning it isn't going to go
anywhere
because when you go to get emotionally
involved and this is the emotional mind
when you go to get emotionally involved
with that white type thought the
paradigm will kick it out you know why
it's so uncomfortable that's stepping
out of the box that's doing things
different and we don't like to do things
different because it causes a lot of
discomfort
but understand this
the paradigm and the thinking control
the vibration you're in and the
vibration is going to dictate what you
attract
people that are in a poverty
consciousness will continue to attract
lack and limitation it has nothing to do
with this what's going on here this is
your educated mind and you could gather
all kinds of information have you ever
wondered why some people have such an
educated mind they have degrees coming
right off the end of their business card
but it doesn't show up in the results
why
paradigm
the law of attraction
you've got to change this
you've got to change the vibration
you're in and your whole world changes
listen in 1961 a man gave me this book
and he said do exactly what i tell you
he was giving me y type ideas it caused
an enormous amount of discomfort but i
did exactly what he said and you know
something
my income went from 4 000 to 175 000 in
a year and then i took it over a million
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out what happened
this is what i'm showing you watch this
over and over and over again there's a
number of lessons in here
and another lesson i'm going to show you
how to change the paradigm when you
change the paradigm the change in
results is automatic you know why you
start to attract something that
something different and what we want to
do is program in positive information
and eliminate the negative
i'm going to show you how to do that
law of attraction
you attract according to the vibration
you're in this thing we live in is a
molecular structure your body is a
massive energy you know if you put your
body in front of an infrared television
camera in a completely dark room your
whole being would be nothing but a
glistening radiating gleaming form
feeling is conscious awareness of the
vibration we're in when we don't feel
good
we're in a negative vibration
you want to feel good move into a
positive vibration stop and think of
what you're grateful for
but understand this
you will never attract to you
wealth happiness health until you get
the paradigm to get you on that
frequency
why did a guy like me change
i didn't believe there was an emotional
or capricious god reached out and said
let's give bob a chance
i didn't believe that
i thought
something's happened what's happened
well i spent nine and a half years
studying
with some absolutely brilliant people
now i formed a good habit over that time
i picked good mentors and that's very
important you can use these films as a
mentor you can you can let me be your
mentor
general i've often heard it said people
that have been gone for a couple of
thousand years can help you more than
somebody that's alive today and i get a
lot of help from people that have been
gone for a long time through their books
and writings so you could use this
series as a mentor
but a habit i formed
right from the first person that helped
me
rey
ray stanford he said do exactly what i
tell you
and for some reason i decided i would
i didn't question him i just did it he
said do it until you find out i'm lying
or i don't know what i'm talking about
and he said i don't lie
and i do know what i'm talking about so
i'm going to say that to you and
hopefully you'll grasp it the same as i
did
do what i suggest in these films until
you find out i'm lying or i don't know
what i'm talking about i don't lie
and believe me i do know what i'm
talking about
many years ago they said by their right
results you'll know them or by their
fruit shall know them i searched every
day and every time i picked a new mentor
and i did pick new mentors i did exactly
what they said
it was difficult at first because what i
was really doing was changing habit
patterns
but they were teaching me things they
were teaching me
information that the average person may
never learn
i developed a very close rapport with
them
and they were brilliant people every one
of them very accomplished
that is a good rule if you want to do
something go to someone who is
demonstrated by results they do know
what they're talking about
ask them what should you do
then do exactly what they tell you
now i know that works
because i'm still doing it
and i do it every day if i take the
areas where i'm a little six bit short
i'm just not really very good and i
didn't go to school so there's a lot of
areas
i'm gonna get the very best
and i'm gonna do exactly what they tell
me
and that's what i did when the man who
gave me this book he said do exactly
what i'm telling you
i did exactly what he said
15 years or so ago
um
well first of all
he became my mentor
and a very good friend read up until he
passed away
our company was having financial
problems all the time
and i could earn all kinds of money but
i don't know how to manage it i wasn't
doing how to run a company i mean i
wasn't designed for that
and um i didn't want to learn it i
didn't even like the subject
but what you need you will attract
and
we had a lady come to seminar was a
securities attorney
she fell in love with what we were doing
she was a
a full partner in a company and
over a period of time she became my
business partner she owns half the
company
but she's the she runs the company she's
the president chief executive
of the company
i mentioned her last time you should get
around for an interview sometime because
she is a fascinating person but she does
a phenomenal job here yeah well so i
have found in the areas that i'm not
really good at
i get the very best
and i work with them i don't try and
learn what they're teaching
i get them to do that i get somebody
else to do something else because it's
going to take me to where i want to go i
have a young guy here that runs our
studio
he's the director of the studio
he's absolutely brilliant
he set a goal when he was 13 to work
with me i remember this he was living in
manchester and england and he watched
the secret and he saw me he said i'm
going to work with him
13 years later he's here in the studio
and he runs this place i love that he's
incredible
he can record and send it from anywhere
in the world he can come in here and do
everything
and i found that's one of the secrets of
getting to where you want to go
you need help you got to have help you
got a lot of help you're saying we can't
just do it all on our own bob
never gonna do it on your own
it won't go very far if you're doing it
alone you should seek failures
see if you're playing it safe you're not
gonna win
if you're playing it safe
like that old saying you know you're
talking you're a little girl better to
be safe than sorry well that's a bunch
of crap it's not better to be safe than
sorry
it's by trying things that you figure
out how far you can go
you got to get outside the box
like it's reported edison
tried three thousand ways before he
built the incandescent light he he said
he didn't fail three thousand times he
said there was three thousand different
steps to building a light bulb
well there's different steps to get to
where you're going and i really do treat
winning and losing exactly the same i do
not let it upset me do you think that's
a big part of why you're so successful
well it's part of why i enjoy it
um yeah i think it is because i try
anything
like if if i'm into an idea
the idea of losing never enters my mind
see i have worked with giants
i had the good fortune of
working with sir edmund hillary
he was the first man to stand on top of
the world
and
i worked with him on three different
occasions
and the only difference in ed hillary
and bob proctor is in his his size now
he's gone now but he was a big man when
he shook hands with me his hand wrapped
right around mine i felt like a
dwarf
you know
and
in talking to him like it never entered
his mind he wouldn't get to the top of
the mountain but he failed in 1951 he
failed in 1952
it wasn't until 1953 that he got to the
top of the mountain now people had died
for centuries trying to do that
he said i knew if i could see it in here
i could hold it out here still a man
wrote that in a book
you can see it in your head you can hold
it in your hand
and that's right
and if you're not prepared to lose
you're never going to win because you're
always playing it safe
and there's no there's no reward in that
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want some amazing
louise hey motivation check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there
there's a substance that is far more
precious and far more important to us
that we literally can't live without
what is that
love no plenty of people are miserable
and lonely most of their life